so six o'clock hello everybody welcome
to planning West the committee members
our counselors are arrayed in front of
me and if I just ask everybody else the
offices to introduce themselves from
over here and funds committee services
Ross chambers legal services my name is
David Jeffrey I'm the Western team
leader in my role as an impartial
adviser to the committee I can clarify
any planning issues that arise in doing
so I am bound by the code of
Professional Conduct to the Royal Town
Planning Institute planning committee
members are not bound by the case
officers recommendation or by oral
advice steer philosophy planning officer
alison young planning ellen about
planning officer lovely so apologies of
absent chairman we have apologies from
councillor pain for whom councillor
fielding is substituting apologies from
council Richards for whom counselor or
Donnell is substituting and apologies
from councils Lawton and Vaudrey lovely
and thank you very much to all our
members for turning up and our subs for
turning up much appreciated anybody have
any disclosures of interest
no okay and is everybody willing to
confirm the minutes of the fourth of
July yes okay good
okay in which case we go into planning
applications I'm going to change the
running order all right I want to bring
forward the final item item eight which
is a street lighting item that's okay
with everybody
good are you ready for that
so if we go straight to item 8 which is
street light in column number 3 on the
Birmingham Road and Stewart will present
us on that Becky chairman good evening
this is a full playing application for
the installation of a CCTV camera on
what is a existing street lighting
column proposed to be installed eight
meters above ground level the
application site is on the Permian Road
right in the town centre our first
traffic on Aven as illustrated here by
the black dots here on this slide the
site is within both the bill to pay a
boundary and town center boundaries of
stratford-upon-avon we're also as is
illustrated by the Purple Line here
within the Stratford conservation area
in addition to being within what is a
designated site of archaeological
interest the existing street lighting
column is situated in front of a run of
four listed buildings as one can perhaps
see here on this plan right by the arrow
here numbers 21 to 25 Berman Road this
is an aerial view just four indicative
purposes to show where the site is in
relation to the centre and here is a
what is a location plan that was
included as part of the application file
here we see an expert of four what is
the CCTV specs as to what the proposed
camera would look like on the street
lighting column and just by means of an
illustration we can see the said column
here in front of traffic court here on
the burning Road and this reflects a
misapplication
there all want to do other photos chair
members
if one people would like to see them but
so that pretty much concludes my
presentation there are no updates chair
on the sheet and I am recommending this
application be granted for the reason
set up pages 70 of your agendas thank
you thank you very much I'd get just to
go to go back on that I think
because this is an application from this
council it has to be heard
we can't just delegate it so we have to
make a vote on this I'm happy to go
straight to the vote coaster Barb's so
we have a proposal and a seconder all
those in favor
unanimous term great so this committee
resolves to grant application number
1801 one two three four lovely that was
the easy one so now on the cycle way
we'll do a lot of people so we should go
back to the running order as in the
agenda item number four in little old
pub on farm and Alison Thank You
chairman this application is a full
application for the erection of a six
thousand ton combine double grain store
as an extension to an existing grain
store and along with associated works
sorry the site is denoted by the black
dot and on the plan their site is
located within the open countryside and
the Greenbelt to the southwest of little
on the application site is edged in red
on this plan the site is accessed for an
existing access road from the be 408
nine this is an aerial view of the site
showing the existing agricultural
buildings on the site the monitor a
footpath is located to the north of the
site and runs in an east-west direction
this is the proposed block plan and
shows the proposed extension which is
sited to the north west of the existing
group of buildings along with a new
concrete hard standing area this light
shows the elevations of the proposed
building in relation to the existing
neighboring building
this photograph is taken from the south
of the existing group of grain store
buildings that can be seen from the
arrow at the bottom this photograph was
taken from the southwest and shows the
position of the proposed building
alongside the side elevation of the
existing building this photograph was
taken from a position to the east of the
site alongside where the access to the
site linked to the road the existing
grouping of buildings can be seen to the
rear of a line of trees this photograph
was taken from the monix way footpath to
the north of the site the proposed
extension would be positioned in the
foreground of the existing building
chairman the recommendation is to grant
the application subject to the
conditions set out on page 17 of the
agenda lovely thank you very much
I think we go now to hear from our
speakers the parish council chairman
councillor Harvey so you'll have three
minutes we'll give you a half minute to
the end warning and you just press the
button and speak some distance away from
it thank you said okay
lovely and thank you very much for
allowing us to speak on this event we'd
also like to express our thanks to the
applicant mr. Turney who has we know
tried to accommodate some of the
objections raised by the parishioners
and we do
wait to that and appreciate it
significantly however we would like us
councillors to still understand the
views of the parishioners which were
expressed extremely strongly to public
meetings and haven't wavered and in fact
people are still raising issues on an
almost constant basis one of the thing
is that we first objected to was the
increased um hgv traffic and whilst the
latest traffic report has addressed that
to some extent and mr. Turney has also
said that he would try and divert some
of the traffic so reducing by the
reducing the overall increase by almost
50 percent this was based on the fact
that the mailing contractor would
cooperate with that but we haven't been
given any detail about how many how much
of that traffic is actually not handled
by the main contractor so those figures
in our view are questionable they may be
accurate they may not in at the moment
we are uncertain as to what proportion
that actually does represent the second
thing is that the be road that runs
through what is a ribbon village is
being quite badly eroded at the moment
with the HTV traffic increase we believe
from the development that was approved a
couple of years back at that time within
the traffic report and the reason we did
not subject the traffic report a report
stated that the traffic would not be
routed through little all in fact all of
it has been and as a result of that we
believe that this is what's been causing
the damage so at the moment I'm
representing the views that
if in the last time there was a
guarantee given that the traffic would
not be routed through the hamlet but
this time there is is questionable as to
whether it will or won't be and
therefore we have concerns as to how
that would be enforced and how it would
be monitored in able to enable that us
to see that something has actually been
done the third element is that there is
quite a lot of noise already from quite
at one end of the handle it the closest
to pools for bond form from noise
reducer iers sorry and we believe that
that current level of noise obviously
will double because we have doubled the
size of growing dryers there so will and
despite the the officers recommendation
it will have quite a significant effect
on people using their gardens and so on
in the summer particularly and the last
element is that just the scale of it
because we believe there is an
alternative which is also earned by the
applicant Crangle park farm we believe
that that would be a more suitable
location because it has almost direct
access 3 min and thank you very much
thank you do we have any questions for
councillor Harvey the noise was that the
current green dryers do make quite a bit
of noise and the residents that are in
that half of the hamlet hear it quite
frequently with this size have increased
that noise will double it can't not any
other questions could we have the map up
the sort of odd Els map you did yeah
it's good you talked about an erode
which reloading and talking about okay
and the alternative you were told
there's be an alternative route that
nothing
would come through little are all last
time yes do you know which route that
would it would be routed through Great
Hall rather than through little and
there is less build-up through that
route and the element that would have
gone through little through Great Orme
is only quite a small stretch and the
houses there in that stretch there
aren't as many fronting the road as
there are in ok thank you no more
questions thank you very much thank you
very much so now we will hear from the
applicant Robin terney
evening and you also have three minutes
it's already on and I'll give you a half
minute warning at the end okay thank you
um we still approximately six thousand
two hundred and fifty tons of our own
grain at pulls barn farm and a further
nine thousand tons for approximately 50
other local farmers within a ten-mile
radius of the site the majority of these
are within the Stratford district so the
Stratford district is a beneficiary of
what we do and demand for our services
from local farmers is increasing your
year as we provide a flexible and
affordable grain storage drying cleaning
and handling solutions we can drive and
store grain as well as clean dirty or
infested grain to improve its value many
farmers are not in a position to invest
in their own storage and drying
facilities and do basically due to their
their of their own situations and a high
capital cost to do so so our central
collaborative facility is quite
important to them as an industry in the
local area there was a real need and
hopefully for this development and if
we're not allowed to proceed it will be
to the detriment of our own business
obviously but also to those other local
farmers and the Transport statements
confirms that additional six traffic
movements per day will be created as a
result of the proposed development
during the harvest period which runs
from mid-july to mid-september and
during the rest of the year the traffic
movement increases will only go up by
1.6 traffic movements when you consider
that we currently split these between
the nickel on route and the grate on
route already as part of an existing
traffic plan with our atoms the holier
our main hornier that would actually
result in only three traffic movements
through little on and three through
Rotom
during the intake period and point eight
traffic movements during the non harvest
period which is effectively October to
June so comments made by the residents
suggest that the beef 4089 is not
suitable for any additional traffic
however these comments and either really
qualified or supported by any evidence
and the fact is that work sure highways
have declared no objection to the
proposal the property positions on the
road in the kalam is no real different
to quite a lot of the other surrounding
villages and the beef 4089 is a bee road
linking Henley an ardent with Ulster and
is a relatively busy road with regular
use by commuters and commercial traffic
and another point I want to raise with
that since we established the store in
2014 there have been no reported
incidents of either traffic related or
noise related that come back to the
grain store 30-second hand okay so the
project will enable A&M Attorney to
reduce movements also between capable
farm and pulls barn farm which is in the
notes again we also have an ongoing colt
a consultation to work with the parish
council an existing and transport
management player plan with our main
hall here which is our items who hold
75% of the material on and off our site
and the traffic management plan includes
store opening time and restrictions I'm
afraid that's it
are there any questions councillor Giles
well I think I would like to just hear
from you about what are the details as a
traffic management planning and I've
probably got to follow up about traffic
management plan
yes if you don't mind just expanding on
what you say so the moment mark and Andy
analyst who wrote run our lives
transport we have three main principles
of what we agreed to they are store
opening times and any restrictions on
movements a route plan to balance out a
movement through the villages so the
principle there is if a lorry comes on
to the site through little arm they have
to leave through great I'll and vice
versa and there's also a speed
restriction on Laura's coming through
both of those villages that we've
imposed and agreed and also general
driver care and General's of management
of drivers they come in and that's a
constant evolving processes drivers
change and we have to talk to each other
on a relative daily basis on that so
it's been alluded to that at some point
there is an agreement that all the
traffic would be diverted through great
on an honesty I think the Paris Council
and the residents misunderstood where we
came forward with our previous panel
occasion it was proposed that we could
split traffic which in fact we would do
anyway but it's perceived that obviously
people can't really count numbers and
what's going in and out it's not that
easy but there was no there was no
requirement or condition on the previous
application in terms of traffic
management so obviously there's no there
was no requirement of us to fulfill any
you know any suppose need or condition
that wasn't enforced upon us so we we
haven't done we we've tried to do it
anyway as part of what we're doing you
know with the elements transport company
and I do listen with interest with what
the Paris have to say and I am you know
a parish member and I care about what
people think and what they have to say
and will continue to engage with them to
do what we can to resolve these issues
management plan as you've outlined were
made into a condition is that something
you would object to not at all I mean
it's in its enforce now and the the
company the principal halt here is on
board with it and you know from their
perspective they're working in our area
they are a member of the community as
much as I am and you are so they're
they're more than happy to sort of
engage and work with us oh great Thank
You councillor Bob it's a mixture of
tractor and trailer so no we store it
and then we out load it to the mills so
for example we're a principal it comes
to us and stays with us okay Kent about
concern tell me the application nothing
no nobody's approached me at all on a
noise level other than when we've
engaged in this process I couldn't I
couldn't give you an honest answer but
it's quite a small Billy okay councillor
fielding two questions if I may
harvesting can go on late at night and
sometimes through the night if it's dry
enough what are you doing with the corn
therefore you're meant to be storing are
you putting it into big lorries and then
waiting until the situation or the
morning comes along so we have a time
restriction so hardest time we open at
7:00 a.m. and close at 9:00 p.m. the
rest of the year we run from an 8:00
a.m. till 5:00 p.m. it's only at the
intake time that we want to late late
night times so what generally happens is
if those guys are still combine
we say fugly trailers and then come to
us in the morning but we don't go beyond
that time I mean all this week we
haven't been going beyond 7:00 p.m.
because it's been a relatively easy and
smooth harvest so far touchwood was
raised it's the noise from the dryer
have you considered baffling the noise
or doing anything to keep that so at the
moment our dryer is inside an existing
building so it's insulated as well as we
can do it funny enough nobody has ever
raised this issue with me before
nobody's ever sort of contacted me and
said that noise is a is a problem we
only want one main continuous flow dryer
which is within an existing building
which is baffled and screened it's
actually quite quiet from the outside
and I mean I I've struggled to hear it
when I'm in the village a little and
when it's been running but you know if
people can they can there is no there is
no proposal in here for another dryer or
any increase to drive capacity so there
is no in there is no direct impact on
that facility there might be a small
proportion of the additional grain that
will be dried but there will be no more
drying infrastructure put in okay cancel
Giles times good lovely no more
questions thank you very much could I
make one more point
I've fraid not okay
if you can retire to the sea for now
thank you sorry about that we haven't
got counselor Gators have we up for
technical questions I think councillor
Giles the applicant referred to I mean
I've seen the assessment in your report
of the different traffic movements and
and actually in some ways some of the
traffic movement is mitigated because
the additional storage allows for fewer
traffic movements but I think the
applicant gave us a summary of saying
six movements a day additionally in the
harvest period and then the rest of the
year would be about 1.6 do you think
that is an accurate summary yeah I mean
that accords with the information that
we've been sent in the traffic statement
Casa bombs noise I think it's through
its through a noise restriction at the
moment or any noise issues councillor
Giles again obviously there is an
informal traffic management plan in
place
given that the applicant says that you
know activity is increasing on this site
and obviously this represents an
increase would it be in no circumstances
reasonable to impose that as being or at
least not the specifics as we've heard
today but the negotiation of a traffic
management plan in accordance with what
we've heard today is a reasonable
condition I think I'd be satisfied on
the basis of what the applicant said and
what I've heard today that that would be
reasonably necessary and relevant to the
planning application before members and
the only proviso to that being that what
we're discussing today is a relatively
modest increase in in HDTV numbers so
that would be something - okay sir
before you go John on that um if we do
resolve to ground this I think members
would probably want from what I
understand
that kind of a condition so would that
be sorted out after after we do or do
not grant or would it be sorted out now
members could if they were inclined to
do so
resolve to grandness with an additional
condition for a reporting respect of
driver care opening times and hgv
routing and other conditions to preserve
the immunity of residents okay thank you
catch me
so the area you can see labeled site
there is the location where the
extension would be as you can see from
this plan this is the extension and
there's an area proposed for a concrete
hard standing so it's not currently hard
standing at the moment is just
earthworks left over from the previous
extension and there was some alteration
of levels in that area as well so that
that's the situation as we find it now
but it would be proposed to be hard
standing okay John
in that respect I think that we
consulted the environmental health
officer and no objections were
forthcoming on the grounds of any noise
partly because there is no proposed
machinery as part of this development
previous application would have included
the details of the machinery for drying
as I say this this doesn't include any
machinery for drying and therefore a
condition which retrospectively sorts a
baffle existing machinery would not
really be necessary or relevant in
respect to this current application ok I
presume but one of the questions would
reduce this activity 24 movements to 3.6
traffic movements per day is the 3.6
from the 7 which appears higher up so
that it is now down to 3.4 was it 3.6
you see yep
no further but clarity my understanding
of that wording is that these there
would be three point six movements
elsewhere in and around the Keadle pool
farm that would be reduced and
eliminated by this development so it
caused clarify where these figures come
from for the traffic estimates provided
in the applicants transport statement
which would have been reviewed by
council officers and also the district
the county highway authority thank you
and well good debate with anyone
councillor John
I think clearly both perish and
applicant have reasonable points of view
which have been expressed and this is
always a question of balance which is
allowing rural business to expand but
also making sure that people who already
live locally are respected and I think
it's it's very pleasant to hear that the
applicant has worked well with the
parish really the impact of this in
terms of traffic are relatively limited
however I think from so I'm certainly
minded to prove the application but I
think what's turning me to water saying
a condition in relation to the traffic
management plan would be reasonable is
that we see the expansion of these rural
sites and they happen piecemeal it's
always very difficult to work out when
you stop putting in a little bit more
restriction and management and I
personally for me I feel the time has
come now we can see it's a business
which very happily is increasing in
activity in size but in accordance with
that I think a little bit more structure
to how it operates is appropriate it
seems as though what's been already put
in place by the applicant is is very
sensitive very appropriate and it might
be helpful for that to be encapsulated
form it formally so I would propose to
grant the application but with the
addition of a condition which is a
traffic management plan will be agreed
with officers largely in accordance with
what is taking place great counselor
Thank You chair um I just like to
support one stick out so Charles has
just said it's refreshing to see an
application where applicant approach
counts of liaised perhaps chemists
actually listened weather seems to be
potentially a formal traffic plan in
place I also share your concerns cancer
Jones about piecemeal expansion and the
impact it has upon the rural
infrastructure but I think it's a
positive application I'll be following
the guidance of the officer to grant
okay caster bounce yes I'm rather
pleased really in the respect that
there's only a one-way traffic because
quite often these
try and clean things up OMA comes and
takes it then brings it back and then
you know it's backwards and forward all
the time and it's pleasing to see that
the first counsel and the farmer or us
talking which is not always the case but
very much like Chancellor Joel said so
the concern obviously like everything is
the road the County Council no objection
is the usual thing but if we can put a a
condition on that is appropriate I do
I'm caught up in a second the
application we have not a proposal yet
are you proposed it did also we had a
proposal and we've had a second before
we vote would anyone else like to say
anything or not
and slacking issues which Council of
Jars lasers are captured in the agenda
will be followed obviously it's
consoling that so far there will be no
residence complaints this is a very
marginal increase and I would assume
that lack of complaint would continue if
there is a problem then of course
redress can always be raised at that
time but I think it's wrong for us to
try and anticipate that so I think
really the spirit of the recommendation
is there and I hope we just proceed with
it as presented okay well we've had a
proposal to grant with an added
condition to be agreed with offices on
opening time speed restriction and
routing I believe we've had that
seconded yeah it is supported by the
board member so I think we'll go to a
vote all those in favor of granting with
the extra condition 5-channel and
against and abstain one yeah I get that
right so this committee resolves to
grant any application 18 zero one zero
zero nine thank you
and will swiftly move on to the next
item airmanship hall not absolutely
and Elinor when you're ready
Thank You chairman this application is a
full planning application for the
demolition of an existing building and
the erection of two dwellings the
application site lies to the east of the
village of barely within the open
countryside and is identified by the
black dot on this plan the site also
lies within the West Midlands Greenbelt
the site is located off the snitterfield
Road and is outlined in red on the plan
it is accessed along a drive of
approximately 500 meters in length from
the main road the site itself is located
within an ancient semi natural woodland
in addition to the east of the site and
to the south of the site like the
snitterfield and bailey bushes which are
sites of special scientific interest
this is an aerial view of the site with
the application site roughly outlined in
red here we have the existing and
proposed site layout the slide on the
left is the existing layout the members
will note the black outline of the
existing building on the right-hand side
we have the proposed layout with plot
one to the southeast and plot two to the
northwest members will also note The
Associated driveways and hard standing
this is a more detailed site layout plan
showing plots one and two with the
associated workshop to the right hand
side these are the existing elevations
of the building on the site to be
demolished these are the elevations of
proposed plot one with the floor plans
illustrating a four bedroom dwelling
which is a single-story accommodation
and with accommodation also to be
provided within the basement here we
have the elevations of plot 2 this is a
five bedroom dwelling with accommodation
spread across two floors this plan shows
the proposed planting and buffer between
the dwellings in the surrounding
woodlands
now have some photos of the site in its
surroundings here we stood at the
entrance to the site on the snitterfield
Road looking up the access drive
standing at the access we're looking
west along this little road which leads
to barely we're now standing within the
application site with the existing
buildings behind us members will note
the access drive which is in the middle
of the photo which stretches all the way
down to the main highway this is the
existing building on the site which is
to be demolished plot one is to be
constructed in this location we're now
looking slightly to the left of the
existing building to the open area of
land where plot 2 is be is proposed and
this is planning further around the site
with the woodland on the periphery
standing slightly further down the
access Drive looking back towards the
application site we can see part of the
existing building on the right plot one
would be on the Left where the existing
building is and plot 2 would be on the
right the existing building is now on
the left-hand side
just outside of the photo and we're
looking towards the open area of lands
that will be in front of plot 2 and now
have a video
so this is panning across the site this
is looking from where plot two will be
located panning across to the existing
building where plot one would be located
and then it's going further around the
entirety of the sites the members will
know the woodland in the background
there are a couple of updates to the
application as detailed on the update
sheet chairman the recommendation is to
refuse the application for the three
reasons set out on pages 34 and 35 of
the agenda thank you so now we shall go
to the speakers and from Bailey Parish
Council in support his counselor Andrew
Spiller so you've got three minutes I'll
give you that a half meter warning just
press the button the red line should
come on when you're ready to begin
the parish supports this scheme as the
redevelopment of a brownfield site
proposals do not harm the openness of
openness of the Greenbelt wouldn't
improve the site the site has been shown
not to be suitable for business use and
for the benefit of the village we fill
two houses would much be better their
new business use especially considering
how busy the road is and most
importantly for the ongoing protection
of the woodland we care about the
woodland and want to secure the best
long-term future for it we believe the
measures proposed as part of this
application can do that and we will
improve on the in current situations
there are currently no controls the
Paris comes will fill the proposals to
Ellen's is the best option for the
village fete thank you very much have
any questions Castle Giles response
provided originally it said the Parish
Council support is subject and the
district council being fully satisfied
in respective technical - matters such
as trees and ecology we've obviously now
had ecological information which
suggests it's not supported with the
application because concerned about the
many risks that there would be to the
woodland
so I'm just I was a bit concerned that
I'm supposed to be surprised that the
parish was still supporting application
in light of that we at least have be
supported in that the no trees were
going to be removed or anything like
that we wanted to keep the you know the
building just on the actual brownfields
sort itself on the existing stand
standing concrete areas and the building
of the existing building that you've
just seen and that's what you know we
didn't want any changes there's there's
no actually woodland management plan at
the moment and there will be so it was
supported on three occasions now I think
okay councillor Barnes
I think I went on start visiting wasn't
no no no no yes it was built by the
Americans
yes years ago yeah sorry
are these buildings these two homes at
the same size of the the original
building
well they on that side there on that
side is our there's a I've been to the
site there is a big concrete hard
standing area which is where the plot on
the left is being about plot to do
that's just hard standing concrete as
you can see yeah Thank You Barry now you
can't pass on the road can you okay okay
any other questions counsel feeling
maybe we can move that to technical yeah
any other questions okay thank you very
much that's great now I think we will
hear from Peter Jenkins the agent who
also has three minutes are with a half
minute warning and it's a little red
button to press or the second plan to be
shown while I speak on this if that's
okay the second landscape plan that's
the one yet thank you good evening this
is the third time at committee for this
application and the first application
was for four dwellings which we were
asked to reduce to two and we did
however this was also refused some of
the members here were out like committee
and may recall the discussion which
centered on two key issues one was the
lack of marketing evidence for the
existing businesses and second was that
more evidence was required on ecological
impact it was also stated that members
disagreed with the officer on Greenbelt
impact and
stainability the officer has since
removed the greenbelt reason from her
report but has retained sustainability
on this issue both local policy a s10
and national paragraph 79 provide lists
which have been agreed at appeal to not
be exhaustive lists the broad principle
of sustainability is the issue to be
assessed the officers report made is on
the reliance of the private car but when
balanced against possible car movements
for the existing use there's no real
argument this is a brownfield site Asin
states one of its key aims is to
prioritize the reuse of brownfield land
and existing buildings which is what
we're trying to do so we move on to
marketing evidence we have now provided
evidence of the estate agents targeted
marketing campaign which includes
responses from five initially interested
parties but with consistent responses
the site's need of improvement to
buildings and infrastructure make it
enviable in addition the current
proposal is for live work units the
existing building supports one employee
the applicant the proposals will improve
upon this with live workspace included
in both swellings it is this kind of
business if any that the site needs to
be most sustainable workers who live and
work on the site so this leaves us with
ecology natural England offered no
objection to the scheme but suggested
details to be secured by condition these
related to a lighting scheme and
drainage strategy which we've provided
both the County Council's ecology team
haven't actually updated their response
since the original submission for for
dwellings where they noted five specific
specific potential impacts we have now
proposed both a written and drawn
strategy to address each concern the
plans can be approved and the owners
would need to apply for permission to
alter them at no point has the county
ecologist balance the existing b1 use
with the proposed c3 use in terms of
impacts this is not just a previously
developed site it is an existing b1 site
with no approved controls and no
management strategy our proposals will
secure detailed design conditions and
management strategies this is a
betterment there is no necessary
increased impact between B 1 and C 3 use
in any event the question I believe we
need to ask is who's more likely to
invest in and care for these woods well
a homeowner who may choose to live here
because of the natural ancient woodland
or a business owner who will see the
woodland as an encumbrance so that
30 seconds I hope you'll be able to
support this application and secure the
best future for the site and for the
woodland thank you thank you
any questions councillor bonds the point
now is he's a big building if the mass
that you're going to have on these two
had it's a decreased volume yeah I don't
have the figures in front of me you can
check that in the technical section and
there's a decreased volume it is in use
it's underused because it's not really
viable for business the applicant
currently uses it for storage of their
business which is struggling which is
why they're trying to see it find a
viable use for the site no that's part
of the issue in the five responses that
we had from the marketing it was
consistent than most of them had issues
with the access lane they would need to
widen it which would have further impact
on the woodland so if you wanted to make
the view on use viable you would
seriously impact this woodland more than
it is already impacted residential
wouldn't need that any other questions
could you very briefly go over the you
said there was a management plan a
woodland management plan I know this is
a five meter so maybe explain the five
meter boundary and the planting and any
plan you're suggesting so is it the the
curtilage of each dwelling is
constrained with a low height wall and a
fence which will keep any pets or
non-native native species of plants at
domestic plants contained within the
domestic curtilage and then in addition
to that we've got a five meter buffer of
squirrel planting scrub is different to
shrubs these are these are native
species that would be chosen
specifically to prevent any ingress into
the woodland at the moment as you saw in
the photos it's completely open anyone
can go in there and any plants and any
species can go in there this scrub
planting will protect
to the actual of what's left of the
ancient woodland completely okay so this
scrub is all those sort of light green
lines all the way down the drive as well
that's right yeah and doesn't have that
at the moment thank you very much any
other questions
no thank you kindly thanks can you turn
so technical questions okay
debate okay my foot pass in relation to
the side and so from this plan you can
see it on the western side of the site
can see the green line so that won't be
affected by the planting of the scrub to
keep keep the planting the trees or is
it go around the outside of the path
isn't within the application site okay
so I got one technical question the live
work aspect of this can you go over that
I didn't catch that in the report and
plans shown for each dwelling do show a
study in each house and they top one has
a study and what too has a study as well
and so that I believe is their reference
to live work unit okay thank you was
there technical question no so we're
going to debate councillor Giles
I read this report very thoroughly and I
think it's I think it's very good report
because I think it would be easy to look
at this application in over simplistic
terms which is there's a big building on
there not particularly attractive let's
do something that looks a bit more
favorable and it's it will be an overall
benefit but I think if you read the
report in detail it that is an
oversimplification of what's going on
here so just firstly about the woodland
I think we have to place very
significant weight on it we have in fact
actually precious little woodland left
in Stratford district that's of the
ancient type there are moves to try and
plant more woodland so I think we have a
particular and special duty to be very
very careful with what we have
ecology have been asked to specifically
consider that issue they have seen them
they have looked in detail at the
mitigation plan that's been put forward
and they have said that they're not
satisfied with it and in particular what
they talk about on page 31 is its what
it is it's about domestic use and it's
about the social impact and I have to
say I think the parish counts and
unfortunately they take too narrower
view of ecology because for them it
seems to be a question of are we losing
any trees are only being chopped down
that's that's not just the issue the
issue is about the impact of domestic
use on ancient woodland and what they're
saying is it's very difficult to
actually control you can have all the
management plans you like but when it
comes to enforcing the impact of putting
domestic day-to-day human use right next
to that woodland when we're talking
about light and the impact that has on
the ecology the the wildlife the animals
particularly with this design which is
an open fronted it's all all glazed
essentially so there will be a big light
impact there it's that in
intensification of human activity and so
I personally find that page 31 to be
very well reasoned and it talks about
ancient woodland being irreplaceable
habitat so for me it's a very strong
reason but this isn't just a planning
application which has one reason for
refusal it has three and that's just one
of them I actually I Tok
leacy the sustainability argument that's
the other reason this report refers to
appeal decisions which support rejecting
this application on sustainability
reasons and I think although I haven't
been on the site visit I know the area
and I think you can see from the photos
I think it's very difficult to argue
that this is a sustainable location in
terms of residential use and I'd be
worried about whether people like the
policy or not have sustainability it is
a policy that is there in the MPP F and
if we keep ignoring it by pretending
that sites which are unsustainable are
sustainable I think it has an impact on
the way we we do things and then the
second thing is you've heard an argument
from the applicant that there is no
business use here but the problem is our
offices have specifically said that they
haven't been sufficient evidence put
forward so at the moment that is an
unjustified assertion by the applicant
in my view because the officers have
said look we've asked for open marketing
we've asked for those things to be done
it hasn't been done properly and we've
seen from the update feet offices still
aren't satisfied with what has happened
so I I'm satisfied that all three
reasons that are there and I would
propose to support the offices and I
would propose to refuse the application
sorry that was a bit long that's okay
first councillor bombs yes I have been
on this side and the building was built
by the Americans in 1942 but I remember
and the Swedes were plenty round the
building so that the Germans couldn't
see it invisible to me the ward is dead
there's no life in that wood the
squirrels gray squirrels had taken over
the Foxes there is no life in that wood
if we did quiet when we were there
there's a lot of lights on the building
you know what I mean obviously so he was
certainly sent I have reason to believe
that this might be a better option and
with the barn conversing changing
agricultural barns and this isn't an
aggregate
- bye aunty - be you know it is an
industrial bomb which won't go along
with today's standards of health and
safety in my personal opinion this is
quite a bit smaller than it was I would
be happy to support this application it
is in an isolated situation not defeat
that and the road isn't good but it
could be made beautiful at the moment is
deteriorating badly and I think a lot of
thought has gone into it and I'm happy
to support it okay do we have a proposal
we've had a proposal already so okay
counselor Atkinson I'm not certain of
councillor Barnes is proposing housing
or the applications we've got submitted
but nobody that can be clarified I mean
the whole thrust of the revised MPP F as
far as business activity in rural areas
is to support them in whatever way
possible even with expansion and that I
think must be returned the report does
tell us that the marketing of the site
to retain that activity has not been
very thrust 'el in my interpretation and
I think that fact alone cannot sort of
afford us to change the officers
recommendation therefore I will second
councillor jobs proposal to follow the
policies recommendation of refusal okay
cancel floating
the current building I can't see it of
much industrial use there's a long drive
which as the comment was about parking
passing places along that drive the
houses are very interesting and exciting
for a site like this I wouldn't like
them in the middle of Stratford but they
are quite an interesting design they
also are basically single-story with the
basement
I've got no objection at all to go
against the officer and and go for
approval okay any other comments before
we go to a vote no so we have a proposal
and a seconder to follow the office of
recommendation to will fuse and we shall
vote on that so all those in favor of
refusing three German and against that
two German so that is carried and this
we've got sorry
okay so we're still carried and this
committee resolves to refuse application
18 0 1 0 8 5 thank you
and the next application is hillside on
harvest and rain which Allison will be
presenting Thank You chairman the
application is a full application for
the erection of a single dwelling the
position of the site is denoted by the
black dot mastitis on the edge of
Alveston which is a category for local
service village the application site is
edged in red the site adjoins hillside
and meadow cottage which are sited to
the north and northeast planning consent
was granted for a replacement dwelling
for hillside in 2017 other neighboring
properties fronting to Alveston Lane an
decided to the south of the application
site the access to the site is via a
long private access drive which says
hillside and meadow cottage this slide
shows the block planned for the
development the footprint of the
proposed dwelling is shown in the red
color the green line to the east of the
site denotes the conservation area
boundary the footprint of hillside to
the north of the site is the footprint
of the replacement dwelling that was
approved in 2017 but construction has
not yet started on this property this
slide shows the elevations and floor
plans of the proposed dwelling the
dwelling would be a 5 bedroom property
with a large ground-floor living space
and attached double garage this slide
includes the extent of the flood zones
the proposed dwelling itself is located
within flood zone 1 well as part of the
proposed garden and the existing access
are cited within flood zones 2 & 3
this slide shows photographs of the site
the top photos taken from the existing
pathway to the front of hillside and the
lower photo is taken from further into
the site this photograph shows hillside
a meadow cottage and is taken from
within the application site this slide
shows photos of the garden area to the
south
the proposed dwelling and this is a
photograph of the eastern side of the
site there are several existing sheds on
the site and the shed to the left of the
photo is in the approximate position of
the access drive this slide shows the
existing access tract to the site which
serves hillside and meadow cottage a
lower photograph was taken in a position
close to where the access meets Alveston
name there's one update on the update
sheet and chairman the recommendation is
to grant the application subject to the
conditions set out on page 49 of the
agenda thank you very much and we'll go
to our speakers and we have no-one from
the town council but objectors Howard
Blessington resident welcome back and
you have three minutes as you know and a
half a minute warning speaking on behalf
of several neighbors who live adjacent
to hillside we collectively oppose the
current application for two principal
reasons first the built-up area boundary
the proposed house is located outside
the built-up area boundary for Alveston
was defined by the latest neighborhood
development plan this was confirmed by
the delegated report on an identical
application which stated that quote the
site lies outside the confines of the
village and that the quote the proposal
does not constitute sustainable
development and is contrary to policies
CS 15 CS 16 and a is 10 while still able
to plan examiner's report in to
thousands of 18 stated that the video
baby should be redrawn to enclose the
entire domestic garden within the
built-up area this is of only limited
way to the determination of this
application insofar as an amended bu AV
the oldest resident has not been
published the precise delineation of the
domestic garden has not been defined and
the neighbourhood plan has not been
subject to a referendum and may not even
be adopted planning law requires that
applications for planning permission
must be determined in accordance with
the development plan unless overwhelming
material considerations indicate
otherwise
whilst the examiner's report is limited
on moderate weight the application site
nevertheless remains outside of the most
recent draft be UAB for Alveston and
there are yet no legal powers for the
boundary to be with redrawn the proposal
therefore remains in conflict with
policy CS 15 CS 16 and a s 10 of the
core strategy and should be refused on
that basis alone
the second reason access road flooding
there is significant flood risk for this
proposal with approximately 120 metres
of the existing driver in flood zones 2
& 3 amazingly the emergency evacuation
route also passes through flood zones 2
& 3 a previous application for for
dwellings was refused on the 2nd of
March 2017 noting that the access road
falls within the same flow zones 2 & 3
nothing has physically changed since
that date the earlier application was
also refused due to the absence of a
sequential test which should have
assessed flood risk at this site against
all other potential residential
development sites in the district it
would clearly have failed in the village
such as Alveston which is bounded by the
river even a sequential test should
always be required because first flood
risk is not a trivial matter and could
impact other parts of the village for
example lower-end second further
development will inevitably be brought
forward incrementally at this site
carefully orchestrated to avoid any
esteems rusher from the sequential tests
and finally there is a known flooding
risk at this site involving a previous
elderly resident 30 seconds we therefore
urge you to refuse this application ok
thank you very much now remember we have
technical questions to come but are
there any questions now I do have one
actually you talked about science
systems not working for me today you
talked about previous applications
somewhere being refused on flooding
grounds over the driveway I think which
applications and where there
in at least three applications the first
was for four houses which was refused
because some of the houses within flood
zones two and three but also because the
access was in flood zones two and three
and also because a sequential test was
not carried out to the satisfied okay
and where was that
on this site or someone on this side
okay thank you very much
okay thank you sorry and now we're going
to hear from the agent Steve Bromley
thanks sue so yes you also have three
minutes with a 1/2 minute warning from
when you wish to begin
Thank You German this is a resubmission
of an application for a single dwelling
identical in all respects to a previous
application that was refused in October
last year the previous application was
refused for one reason only that the
site was considered to lie outside the
confines of the village of Augustine the
application site is garden land hillside
it has all of the characteristics of a
garden with decorative planting and
ancillary buildings the site does not
does not have any of the characteristics
of open rural landscape or countryside
the location of the proposed house is
closely associated with existing
dwelling and with neighbouring blowings
the application site is clearly within
the physical confines of the settlement
since the previous refusal the issue of
defining a built repair boundary for
Alveston has been considered in detail
by the independent examiner for the
stratford-upon-avon neighborhood
development plan the examiner in their
final report has concluded that the
entire domestic garden to Hill site
should be within the VAB as reported in
the committee agenda the Town Council
and the NDP steering group have
indicated they will accept the
examiner's recommendation and the site
will be included within the Alveston be
UAB the development is therefore in
compliance with policy for the location
housing on it on other issues the
application includes a comprehensive and
detailed flood risk assessment prepared
by consulting engineers who specialized
in is a very technical area of expertise
the assessment of flood risk by the
Environment Agency has included a
computer model modeling exercise for the
site and the site is in the house will
be sited entirely within flood zone 1
which is an area which is has the lowest
risk of flooding flood zone 1 is deemed
to be the most suitable land for
development the the Environment Agency
have confirmed they have no objection to
the development proposed
the previous speaker has referred to a
sequential test I should say there's no
legal requirement for sequential test
it's a matter of policy have to consider
each case on its merits the previous
speaker referred to a previous
application where an application was
refused because it was no sequential
test that was a different proposal for
four houses two of which were were
proposed in flood zone two we're not
proposing any development in the flood
zones two or three and that's the
important difference thirty seconds the
proposals offer a well-designed house
using high-quality materials include a
mix of brick and render set on the stove
in the design and scale of the house
will be in keeping with local character
the site is well screened by amateur
planting and integrated within the
landscape chairman the proposals are in
accordance with the development plan and
will provide a carefully designed form
of sustainable development thank you
very much
are there any questions cancer Atkinson
yes they're on page 47 of the reports
the third paragraph concentrates on the
Environment Agency has carefully
assessed the proposals I'm not certain
what some of these expressions are the
finished floor levels are set at 39.95
aod what that is I don't know well above
the one on 100-year event on 600
millimeters above the is that 1000 year
event so tamai can I take confidence
that this application will have no flood
factor based upon that information I
mean it unless we have given next week
have another but was it Moses yeah yes
that's a different thing entirely but
could you explain what a ody means us
above ordinance days them and the
standard is you have to set minimum four
levels 600 millimeters above the maximum
recorded flood level which this would be
so nice this property it would not
flood see thank you apart from Moses we
appear obviously capsule bombs it's
saying that it could be in the village
boundary now it's a battle of judgment
as to whether we're the Bui B should
finally be drawn the independent
examiner for the neighbor development
plan has clearly expressed to you in two
different places in her final report
that this the whole hillside it should
be within the boa be like I just add one
more thing to that the policy on this
says CS 15 says that development has to
be either within a be UAB or with where
there is no big you may be within the
physical confines of the settlement and
it is clearly within the physical
confines of our wisdom thank you one
replacement dwelling has been granted is
that on the same site or we're talking
about now it's immediately alongside and
that was accepted
okay it's the one to the north there any
other questions no thank you very much
and we will hear from the ward member
can sort of love who has up to five
minutes five minutes it there five
austerity sorry okay firstly I'm a
little disappointed that the planner
suggested I withdraw my objections to
this proposed application that she told
me that the built-up area boundary issue
had been sorted I refused her request on
the grounds that I support the majority
of residents and that the built-up area
boundary issue was not the only reason
for objecting it may have been the only
reason given under delegated
powers for the same application which is
now being decided by an inspector but
there are other reasons it's important
to refuse this application I would like
to point out that this very same
application is the subject of a written
appeal and the other planner in a
written document to the inspector has
suggested that this application should
be refused she states in her report at
the end that no referendum date has been
set and now and that for the reasons
detailed in the delegated report the
inspector is respectfully requested to
dismiss the appeal so you see it's all
very confusing to myself in the
residence as to why this application is
now being put forward for granting built
up hiring a boundary this location may
have been added to the neighborhood
development plan at the suggestion of
the inspector but the Neighborhood
Development Plan has not been adopted
and it hasn't even gone to referendum
what if the neighborhood development
plan is not voted in favor
I suggest we are premature and allowing
this house to be built landscape
sensitivity this very council
commissioned the report on landscape
sensitivity in Alliston
and it will suggest it in the report
that this area of land is not suitable
for building on why is this report why
in this report is it now okay to build
here anyway is it okay to build in a
garden isn't this background development
as you know feel very strongly about
building in gardens and we mustn't set
any president ever flooding the proposed
house in flood zone 1 the garden and
access is in flood zones 2 and 3 if
there were to be extreme heavy rains
more water would flow down the access
road and onto the lane and into the
Rookery water already builds up at the
bottom of the access road when there is
normal rain the applicant has planning
permission to replace his own small
house with a very large five bedroom
house with a lot of froth standing for
parking as well this will undoubtedly
increase flooding further down the
Environment Agency has made as made no
mention of this water has to go
somewhere and it will go downwards and
if the second
goes ahead there will be even more
flooding down in flood zones 2 & 3 why
is it but it's now ok with the planner
to put a house here when there are other
areas within Alveston which can be built
on but are not in flood zones we have a
healthy housing supply so we shouldn't
be risking houses in areas with close
proximity to flood zones as I said
before we have a healthy housing supply
and no adopted neighborhood development
plan therefore there is no reason
whatsoever to allow this house to be
built at the moment we shouldn't keep
changing our minds as to how much weight
is put on the emerging neighborhood plan
to suit specific requirements there is
no wait until the neighborhood plan is
adopted and that could be months or even
years this application should be refused
for the reason is given by Howard and
myself or at least a third until the
inspector has made a decision
it would seem ludicrous if the inspector
dismisses the appeal and you as a
committee approved the application defer
or refuse I believe it's your only
choice thank you any questions
councillor Giles first there's been many
occasions on which parishes and possibly
even you who have come before committee
and several actually emerging policy is
very relevant because it's something
that's being designed by the people this
is a neighborhood plan is something
that's been looked up by the independent
inspector and this specific issue has
been addressed within it that's not
going to be challenged so whether or not
this this plan Oh
overlord is approved on a referendum
this particular part this particular
dispute appears to be settled so do you
not actually think that this committee
should be provoked putting some weight
on it well no because it's not being
adopted the name
morale has not been adopted yes there is
wait but how much weight do you give it
I know it's very easy
we've all been here we've also no weight
or loss of weight but at the moment it
is in a garden remember that it's not it
may be the inspector thought it would be
okay but this house is going to be built
in a garden next to flood zones two and
three I'm so done has there been much
discussion between the applicant and the
parish council do you know or yourself
regarding these concerns no any other
questions
cast a verdict when or how far advanced
is the neighborhood plan have you has it
come to its the the district council if
we cover that and technical again
because we can get an exact date I think
discussion so thank you very much
councillor so if we go to technical
straight away who asked that one how far
advances enable and will it into
examination we've had the examiner's
report as you've heard there is no
referendum date as yet but we as officer
consider this part is advanced and we
would give it a significant wait okay
counselor bombs but when it went to the
inspector the first or second time
that's when he made these
recommendations which haven't been come
to the public part is that correct no I
understand it this is partly the
examiner's report and it's got to go
through the referendum process
okay so Giles then point the counts are
all for me I know it is addressed in
your report but but is that we have our
own landscape sensitivity study and
obvious
in some ways what's in the neighborhood
emerging Neighborhood Development Plan
conflicts with that because that the
implication is that it's actually
acceptable to build here so where are
you striking the balance in terms of
what weight we should place on the
emerging neighborhood development plan
and our own landscape sensitivity study
so having done a site visit and looked
at this site in particular and the
surrounding landscaping it's very well
enclosed I don't feel it's a
particularly sensitive site when viewed
from any public vantage point
okay Council Atkinson also council
thanks javelin can we up so we get David
finish on that point I didn't realize it
was he more to say if you bear with me a
moment thank you I think I just wanted
to contribute that in respect of the
weight to be afforded the neighborhood
plan it is an emerging plan as we move
through the process plans do gain weight
up until the point that they are adopted
and then they become part of the
development plan it's not the case that
policies in emerging plans have no wait
until the point they are adopted the
question before members in respect of
the built up area boundary is therefore
to look at the evidence in respect of
the site visit photos you have before
you and to consider the neighborhood
plan the comments of the examiner in the
absence of any other plan which
identifies an alternative built-up area
boundary even if the conclusion is that
the neighborhood plan
authority haven't provided a comment
they're not consul T for less
significant development in respect of
this site the Environment Agency are the
Consul T for matters relating to flood
risk although there are access over the
flood zones in this site the proposed
dwelling is located in flood zone 1
which is the lowest risk of flooding
it's not in the operating flood zone and
so there's no displacement of flood
waters that will occur as a result of
this building very more to the rain when
heavy rain is running down the roads
that are causing problems at on the
highway or wherever as
- bye counselor Ralph causing a problem
as I say that this proposed dwelling
sits within flood zone 1 it's not going
to call this more rain to fall on flood
zone 1 on the siting of this building
will still do so and will drain towards
the operating flood zones which are not
where this building is sited the
Environment Agency have given detailed
consideration of the drainage aspects of
this development and they are laid out
on page 47 they conclude that although
there will be some flooding of the
access that's not detrimental to the
operation of this site for domestic
purposes and the siting of the building
itself is acceptable just basically the
drainage away from at the bottom of the
road there that concerns me whether it's
going into an open ditch or it's going
into drains is it a runoff question
we're talking him yeah there's a
condition proposing a surface and foul
water drainage details to be secured as
part of the application outside of the
application site drainage will remain as
it exists it's going can't just okay so
don't just come back to Council for
dealing with flooding can I just care
for my it seems to me that the
sequential test didn't happen because it
wasn't there so fit to be applied and
with regards to the flooding for the
entrance that garden it could be that if
there is flooding there me residents are
simply stay until it's subsides which
could be a couple of hours but how do we
know that it will just be a couple of
hours and I think the concern is where
does the extra water go once it drains
away was up the I'm still not clear as
to where that is because I you know it
is prone to flooding in that area and
we've seen we have pretty unusual
weather patterns of them
in some disinterestedness - is it
acceptable to expect residents to stay
within a property because we know
potentially that entrances to that
property could flood and how does that
then link in with emergency if
something's happening and they can't get
to it simply because it's flooding and
when you potentially it would flood any
way in its the entrance to a residential
property yes sir these details are
within the report on page 47 it does
describe how within flood zones 2 and 3
there would be a risk of flooding but
that there would be a limited time
period for which the access would would
be potentially impassable but that that
falls within acceptable parameters as
far as the Environment Agency were
concerned with respect to the sequential
test because the built form of this
development is outside of flood zones 2
& 3 it didn't trigger a requirement for
a sequential test now I understand
what's in the report but I was just
clarifying that they're saying it's okay
for a residential property to be
inaccessible for a couple of hours if
there's flooding and we know that that
potentially is a risk for that property
that's that's basically what you're
saying okay just one for me a city is in
the built up area boundary you can you
could still use character presumably if
you if you wanted an argument if you
thought the character of the village
would be changed by building behind
these other other houses and sort of
creating a new road rather than an
isolated dwelling that would be a valid
argument within policy yes so they're
essentially two separate considerations
so if it's it if we're looking at the
principle of development and whether or
not this is within a village within a
sustainable area an area in which the
core strategy expects to see housing
development then we consider our builder
barrier boundaries set apart from that
policies such as cs9 considered the
character of an area
and whether or not it would be
appropriate in terms of character and
appearance design overall amenity for
that development to occur in the way
that he's been proposed okay and I'm
gonna ask for some guidance on this as
well now we have I'm not actually I
think we're just unless there's any more
questions if we get a debate councillor
fielding I am concerned because having
spent a lot of time fishing up to me
what nots in water rivers can go up and
they can take time to come back down
again and therefore I would like to have
as part of the conditions that a proper
drainage system be agreed with your good
self before we give the final details of
an approval on it if that is possible
what are you looking forward to achieve
I'm looking for is a to stop it flooding
those houses at the bottom of the garden
on the south side because the waters
going to go somewhere which way is he
going to go is he going to go back into
the river is there going to be some sort
of stream there it does concern me that
it can go up for two hours well rivers
don't stay up for two hours they can
stay up for days okay thank you
anyone else councillor jar okay to
address the flood issue first after them
I'm not overly concerned about the
impact of this particularly built form
on the other parts of the flood zone
because it's relatively minimum what I
can understand that concern about runoff
when you've got you know a big estate of
houses and questionable impact but I
think we've got to think about the size
of this proposal and the reality is the
Environment Agency is happy with a
situation where you have a potential for
an access to be flooded for a period of
time and essentially what they're saying
is you've got to look at the velocity of
this particular River this isn't the
River Severn it's the River Avon and
you've also got to look at the fact that
people get a lot of notice if there's
going to be flooding and so actually in
those circumstances if isn't a flooding
to the access and
and let's be honest it's not like you
couldn't actually access this property
in an emergency if you have to because
flus so one is to the north
so people presumably will make a
pragmatic arrangement to enter from
another place even if it wasn't a
permissible accesses search so I have to
have to say I'm not I'm not only
aggravated by that issue in terms of the
built aperi boundary I I always I'm very
consistent in this committee to say that
I'm very interested in emerging policy
and I don't think it is appropriate
often I don't often think we place
enough weight on policy just because it
hasn't quite gone through that final
stage you know to me we've had an
independent inspector that examination
has taken place not I agree I think we
should play significant weight I know it
might not be the conclusion that's liked
by local residents but it's still it is
the most up to date policy that has been
through you know there's been a lot of
input into that so have to say for all
of those reasons I'm quite satisfied
with the reports not be happy to grant
the application is that a proposal just
it can be seconded providing as I say
some sort of we get some idea of the
drainage system that will take the
floodwater away and be written into the
conditions at the end of it but I'm
prepared to second everything that was
on the table so if we go back can I just
I mean there is a condition here for
subsurface and fire water fowl drainage
so I don't know whether that meets the
concern of counts of fielding I think
we've got to compromise on it and I
suppose yes I will I'll accept that but
okay since earned okay I will note that
and what we can cancel Adkinson yes
chairman there's so much here which
meets policy to ignore it would be
pointed out frankly some expressions
have come up about background
development if you read inspectors
report
peels they tell you there's no such
thing as bad land development it's not
in policy at all if you want to ignore
the valid opinion of the Environment
Agency about flooding then you're acting
in a basis that you think your knowledge
is superior to them I just cannot see
anything wrong with this application
going to appeal his being mentioned this
calendar year more than 70% of appeals
have been allowed this would be one
which I think would come into that
category
whilst it's been proposed and seconded I
hope Chairman we can rapidly come to a
decision
so do I our Casa bans environmental
energy my villages if they say it's okay
then okay can I just double-check this
is this a condition down here on surface
drainage number six can we give some
more weight to that and sort of confer
with me on that before it's signed off
is that possible a chair happy to agree
the wording of that condition with you
okay good so we have we happy with that
okay thank you for listening I think
it's important we do discuss reports in
fact does not concerns at the point of a
committee and your question report it's
not because you feel you're superior to
the experts you'll simply discuss in the
first second I thank you for taking that
on board and listening because my
concern was about the flooding for the
entrance you know I disagree because
we're going to access that but my
concerns have not been allayed but thank
you for listening and taking that on
board
thank you for point so we have a
proposal and a seconder to grant this
with a slight change of agreeing the
drainage with the chair all those in
favor
unanimous Jen great so
this committee resolves to grant
application 1801 602
good good and now we go to up
application of field view Croft lion
temple Grafton and
Thank You chairman this application is a
retrospective application for the
erection of a wooden shed the
application site lies to the north of
Temple Grafton as identified by the
black dots on the plan the site is
located off Croft Lane and is within the
existing permitted gypsy and traveler
site a public footpath runs
approximately 95 meters away to the
south of the site here we have the site
plan showing the location of the shed
colored in red these are the elevations
of the of the shed which measures 2.6
meters high four point eight meters wide
and two point eight meters deep we now
have some photos here we're standing
within the site looking towards the shed
here we stood at the entrance to the
site looking towards pitch one the
existing brick built day room is located
to the right of the photo and the shed
is set behind this building we now stood
towards the eastern part of the site
looking up towards the shed the roof of
it is just visible between the day rooms
standing on the road now looking towards
the application site the roof of the
existing day room can be seen to the
left of the photo and the roof of the
shed to the right of the photo there are
no updates to the application chairman
the recommendation is to grant the
application subject to the conditions
set out on page 59 of the agenda thank
you very much and we are going to hear
from the applicant Reisman
and welcome back to you as well
three minutes with their half a minute
warning just wanna point out there's
just a wooden garden shed for the
long-nosed and storage that's about it
thank you very much any questions I
catch the bounce going to build it just
again [ __ ] cancer jars last last
application was retrospective and this
is it is there a reason that there
wasn't an application in advance of the
build
there was a strong put a request in heat
for a wooden shed and they he had plan
of a wooden shed and get a wooden shed
save use it or put it over to the table
and he said get me on [ __ ] it's just a
wooden [ __ ] okay cancel Adkinson okay
any more questions thank you very much
and we will hear from the word member
cancer Adams and eyes up to five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman
this is yet again a respect a
retrospective application temple Grafton
Parish Council and not here this evening
because they feel they cannot change the
outcome of the recommendation of the
reporting pace and feel that the
committee didn't really listen to their
concerns last time their objections
remain and can be seen on page 56 but we
cannot understand how a s-10 can be
quoted in the report as a reason to grab
this application a s-10 requires there
to be a significant benefit to the local
area
we certainly don't see any my concern
yet again is the number of structures
that are on this site there is already
permission for five mobile homes five
day rooms five touring caravans a shed
the planning permission was granted in
September 17 and recently a portaloo
which no action can be taken on as it's
not fixed this site is in open
countryside in art and special landscape
area and the inspector did say at the
appeal that this area requires
protection the parish counts are also
noted that measures agreed to screen the
site as discharged by the amended site
planning 17 have not been carried out
and the picture of that shed does not
look to me as a skewer shed looks more
like an outbuilding
rather than a Sakura shed thank you
thank you any questions no thank you
very much and we're going to technical
questions cast about
we can build two meters and it's 2.6
meters to the ridge counselor Giles it's
raising the report that the Parish
Council are concerned the previous
condition to screen site hasn't been
carried out and I just wondered what the
update was on that weather to what
degree we might be allowed to take that
into account on this planning
application and whether that can be
renewed as a condition as part of this
application and so when the original
application was determined at Appeal for
the permanent use of the site as a
Egyptian traveller site a condition was
put on by the inspector requiring some
landscaping details and this plan and
was submitted to discharge that
condition and shows landscaping to this
northern boundary and eastern boundary
as well as landscaping within the site
between the pictures and I have been on
site and I have seen landscaping planted
down the northern boundaries and I
believe that landscaping has been
implemented but obviously that would be
a separate matter and if it was felt
locally that hadn't been implemented to
raise with our enforcement team and I
think in respect of the positioning of
the shed which is over here on the
left-hand side and that is away from any
of the proposed landscaping anyway and I
don't think it in officers view would be
necessary to impose any further
landscaping conditions on the site okay
coastal flooding
yes as a highway verge and then the
fence and then the application site I
wouldn't believe
so unless they got the permission from
the Highway Authority yes and it's not
immediately abutting the fence so
potentially as there would be room to
put some landscaping okay any other
questions cows arkinson I see that given
on the 2nd of March we're now up to the
15th of August you told us it had only
been there for two months
what was the officers impression when
they did a site visit and when was that
site visit and is it something which we
would be happy if we had the benefit of
that ourselves and so this photo here is
dated the 28th of February 2018 and so
that's where my site visit was carried
out okay any other questions no now I
don't think we need to side was it did
you want to propose a cyber visit George
okay
it's a seconder for that oh we need a
reason I'm sure we'll think of a reason
but why would you run beside was it
hunted okay is the second of that no
sorry so I'll make some comments to
start with in debate I note that the
concerns of the Parish Council and the
ward members particularly the fact that
you know they don't think they can
persuade us because of what happened on
the last very very similar shed I note
that yes we are in a special landscape
area and yes there was a specific we
have to make an application even for
shared here which is unusual obviously
normally you just go and put one up and
I underst I understand that but I think
that this this requirement to make a
planning application for anything it is
to take into consideration that yes this
isn't the open countryside and special
landscape so if anything is proposed
which threatens that then yes we have
the power to or yeah we have the power
to to stop that to the best of our
ability but we are talking about a
garden shed up against a fence behind a
hedge and I think there's it's very
different and I think you've got to
remember what we're looking at and I
quite agree that this is retrospective
again and I'm very disappointed
incredibly disappointed to see the same
yet next door to the same site come
forward yet again retrospectively when
they were told last time they were here
I'm quite certain that we don't like
retrospective you know we like to go
through the proper processes that
everyone's supposed to go through
however we've got to look at this as if
it wasn't retrospective and it is just a
garden shed so that was one thing I
wanted to talk about but I've got
carried away oh yes I'm also concerned
about you know
you know development and an increasing
development on this site from what was
originally granted but the
recommendation has as a condition I
think the the point number two which is
this building hereby permitted shall be
used solely for the purposes of domestic
storage ancillary to the occupation of
pitch one that sets my mind at ease so I
am in favor of granting this application
I make that proposal if I could first
I'm wondering and if you could I'm sorry
should of us there's in technical
questions but it's just occurred to me
before this map you can show me where
the other shed is and where the portal
is so I've got a bit of and so the shed
that was previously granted at committee
is over here and there is a portaloo and
immediately to the south of the shed
thank you the applicants comment that
it's just a shed because the problem
that you've got here is when you spectra
prove this when this was an approved
site obviously one of the things that
was seen as hopeful about that plan is
that it was symmetrical in terms of the
built form and therefore neat and that
the built form is there to preserve the
open nature of where we are now I have
to say I don't think that this shed tips
me over the balance in saying this is a
piece of a piecemeal addition that harms
the landscape and harms the site but I
have to say we're coming close to
getting there because I think this is
the risk that the applicant takes with
making repeated retrospective
applications and he didn't answer my
question properly there was no reason
whatsoever given to me why it should be
retrospective is that next time
committee just says no and you take it
down so you can build something but you
you need to be aware that the risk is
this committee refuses it next time and
says well actually we're not how we feel
now we've slid over the line in
what is acceptable piecemeal I don't
feel that this [ __ ] has quite taken is
there probably because of where it's
sited I'm sad to hear that the parish
council don't feel that we listen
because to be fair last time I did take
seriously the fact that it was a an
addition that takes away from that
symmetry but I think in fairness to the
applicant they are cited in places which
don't do too much harm but I think
increasingly there will be a concern
that this site starts to become
cluttered and is moving away from the
template that was originally envisaged I
would encourage the applicant to speak
and communicate with the parish council
because we've seen on our first
application that is something that you
know it enables this committee to make
fairer and better decisions and it's a
bit sad actually that there doesn't
appear to be that level of communication
and those lines need to reopen so I am
minded to say grant but I have to say I
say it was a degree of reluctance
because I want the applicant to
understand that actually the lack of
dialogue the retrospective nature of it
the piecemeal incursion is not something
that in in many ways is desirable and I
do share a degree of skepticism about
whether this is just a shed for tool
storage because it doesn't quite look
like that I don't think it is harmful in
the way it is and where it's positioned
but it's not just a shed actually from
from what I can see so it for me it is a
reluctant support of that proposal okay
building planning officers turn down a
retrospective shed in one of my Awards I
think that prepared to accept it but I
would like to see some trees planted or
up against the fence there to basically
improve the dead wood that is part of
the highways just to give it a bit more
protection and also there's that gap
which we can see at the bottom though
that I think is meant to be part of
looks like it's sort of an entrance or
an exit into the Sun South Side
or two ought to be closed up an effect
proper fence landscaping should we put
in place there but apart from that I'm
happy to go along so long as that can be
made a condition okay any other comments
no the pub's o.cache about I do know
this size and that some shade down there
once but I think the problem that we
have if you like is that we can't put a
condition on to say that any other
development over two meters would need
planning permission and you know
obviously enforcement will see that the
boundary landscape is done but that's
all we need to so that when they do
start we can say hold on because in
theory that is a nice area open area and
it shouldn't have a lot of shades on it
but I think we've got to accept this one
just don't even trust how much notice do
people get for a site visit he's on this
booked in way in advance and site visits
can be just carried out on the day and
and just turn up without notice and I
believe in this instance I did phone
ahead to say that I was coming to get
access to the site and it was probably
just a day in advance okay is there a
concern that this could be used for
something other than storing equipment
and is that something that the condition
can be placed on because from a security
perspective it's a beautiful-looking
shed with there is a condition on that
yeah any other covers no just a comment
is it possible to put a condition in
about planting either along the verge
where the existing trees are or in the
in the property and I don't believe it
would be possible to condition planting
on the verge because that's not within
the applicants ownership and planting in
between the shed and
the fence could be conditions if members
considered that to be reasonable okay
thank you
well I don't so my proposal stands
without an additional condition on
planting that was still seconded the
problem is any planting is not going to
be seen any way because if the height of
the defense or to be honest I think it's
going to be a little bit redundant so I
would be happy to second the proposal I
understand the desire but you cannot go
to buy a tree big enough to make a
difference so I would support that
second it okay so we've had it with a
proposal on a second I don't mind it you
can vote against this and then propose
the same thing with a condition if you
wish as the next proposal but but it
stands without the condition proposed
seconded so we will vote to grant this
application all those in favor
thank you against and abstain one
channel so this committee resolves to
grant planning application 1800 one six
seven thank you very much there is no
urgent business so we're finished thank
you very much
[Applause]